are you sure you're not gonna miss all
of this I've had enough excitement for
one lifetime
I've given what payment I could ever see
are you gonna give now Danny yes your
grandmother said you're becoming your
nurse here says you're doing very good
no we're not nothing who's ready for
some tea
well look who it is you know I don't
send you're trying to rumor the last
time I saw if I could make it up to you
I would I don't really why don't you
tell us a little bit more about your
granny what are you doing tonight so I
was thinking maybe we can go get a drink
it'll do you some good to get out of the
house you're gonna wake the old lady all
right quick grab in and out I'm
surprised you asked me out did you think
you won't my type no I just thought you
game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once we get that safe open she dies
special reconnaissance thinks she's got
a lot more interesting
she's still here how do you know let's
just say crazy knows crazy we're dealing
with nurse Jason Bourne here or
something for the Marines myself well
you know what to say join the airforce
if you have no guts
when Marines if you have no brains seven
in with two of you running off to the
Caribbean
[Music]
this is the most fun I've had in years
[Music]
Hey starting to feel really sorry for
you
you